seton and the french kid got in the
sprinter van moments ago and i felt like
i was sending my son off to college gave
him the credit card and uh they got in
the sprinter van if you're watching on
peacock you can see this it's an
unbelievable machine and they're taking
it out supposed to be in los angeles by
sunday
and we're giving away that sprinter van
175
000 entries that's 100 000 more than we
had last year so thank you to this
audience and we'll let you know we'll
keep you updated on where seton will be
i know first stop is cincinnati and a
great time to be in cincinnati seton is
getting a pie to the face
he had kansas city we had one of our
listeners from cincinnati saying he'd
take a pie to the face if uh the bengals
lost well bengal's winning first stop
cincinnati and seton has to track down
this gentleman and get a pie to the face
along the road he then goes to nashville
memphis
arkansas albuquerque i think vegas is in
there uh phoenix arizona's in there then
los angeles and parts in between what
could go wrong um
look at road tripping seating in the
passenger seat the french kid is uh
behind the wheel how are we doing how's
progress there
all right so far so good uh we made it
through new york city which feels like a
major victory
how many miles have you guys driven so
far we had the over under at 99 and a
half
oh uh we're under yeah we're at about
just about to hit 77. yeah paulie and i
went the under because we thought it was
going to take you a little time to uh
find the gas
gas cap and and find diesel
well
well your instincts on that weren't
wrong uh yeah the first fill up we we
got there we it took us probably a
little longer than it should have uh but
we did get through the first fill up
which is nice okay cincinnati is still
the destination for later on today slash
tonight
that is still the destination wait i can
say this will absolutely be in
cincinnati tomorrow morning
okay now what about what about the bet
that you have with the cincinnati fan
when are you supposed to take the pie to
the face
uh tomorrow morning oh okay you've been
in contact with him
yeah yeah yeah i've been uh emailing
with him and he's really excited i think
he might be more excited to smash me in
the face of the pie than he is about his
bengals winning but it's close
how does the sprinter van look how's it
riding dude it's awesome it is it i
can't even begin there's the french kid
he's driving he's been doing a pretty
good job actually um
the uh no the sprinter van is amazing
it's it's unreal uh just how
gorgeous it is
and uh you got a lunch place that you've
scouted out
well we're heading through new jersey so
uh it's looking like we're either
getting some pork roll sandwiches or
maybe we wait until philadelphia get
some cheese steaks that's what we're
figuring out we're just having that
conversation all right we'll keep us up
to date and once again let me know when
you get there
and uh i just want to give fritzy a
heads up then in about 10 minutes from
now in the first segment you're going to
ask for pull this off
that's nice
thanks a lot i'll give you a heads up
that is coming dan is going to put you
on the spot piling it on from the road
it is it
it is not good you know todd can't
handle the poll question very mentally
taxing on me here uh do you have
the best and worst of the weekend seaton
while i have you
uh my best of the weekend sure was t
higgins uh dude absolutely bald he
doesn't get nearly the uh amount of
recognition maybe um but he had a great
game my worst of the weekend was the u.s
men's team laying an egg against canada
they played really well they just didn't
win that's incredibly frustrating all
right well uh safe travels and uh keep
us up to date
all right see ya that's seton o'connor
with the french kid on the road looks
good looks like they know what they're
doing